احنا كده يا هوا جون مساء الخيرات على
حضراتكم طب ما انا برضو ما عنديش
الكومنتس فين انا اه هنا زحر
تمام لا لسه الناس ما دخلوش اوكي وعليكم
السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته اظن ان
الكومنتس اه بدات ايه تجنا ربنا يخليك عمر
ا انا في انتظار اسئلتكم ولكن لغايه ما
تيجي الاسئله بدات الاسئله تيجي اهو
العتاب كبير جدا استاذ سيد دي اسئله كثيره
لحظه لحظه لحظه لحظه نبدا بس العتاب كبير
جدا استاذ سيد خلال هذه الفتره التي لم
تظهر فيها ببث مباشر وكنت انت مصدر وصاحب
المعلومه الدقيقه المجرده لقد كنا في تشتت
لان معظم القنوات على يوتيوب هي صحافه
صفراء اخونا ام ار ايه رايك يا صديقنا
تكتب لي اسمك باللغه العربيه والانجليزيه
علشان اعرف ادعوك يعني
سامحني هو كان في اسباب متعدده منهم سبب
ما حدش يتخيله يعني انا كان عندي مشكله
انتم عارفين اللي عايش في مصر واللي
بيتابع الاخبار سياسه معلنه تخفيف الاحمال
للكهرباء لمده ساعه ده لا يبدو انه مشكله
كبيره يعني انما هي انا ببقى مش دايما
متاكد الساعه دي امتى في الفتره اللي فاتت
ا انه الانترنت احيانا تبقى الكهرباء
موجوده والانترنت مش موجود ببساطه لانه
المنطقه اللي هي مصدر الانترنت قطعت عنها
الكهرباء ف كان واحد من اعتبارات تانيه
سامحوني ان شاء الله ننتظم قدر الامكان
وشكرا لاهتمامك وتقديرك ورسالتك الطيبه
احمد ادم السلام عليكم عليكم السلام
السلام عليكم شباب كتير وعليكم السلام رنا
سالم عمر وحشتنا استاذ سيد ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك
ا انا عشان
الاسئله طيب اهلا وسهلا عبد الله حسام
ربنا يخليك يومك سعيد الله يخليك ويسعدك
يا محمود اهلا سيد شكرا جزيلا فيصل السلام
عليكم نورتنا استاذ وعليكم السلام عبد
الله عواقب الغزو البري ده اول سؤال من
اخونا زيزو منصور يا صديقي الاول عشان انا
المفروض ده الموضوع الرئيسي اذا اقدمت
اسرائيل على الغزو البري انا لما بقول اذا
معناها ان المساله ممكن تكون محل شك
اسرائيل بتتكلم عن الغزو البري منذ تقريبا
يعني
ا انفقت من الصدمه الاولى يوم 7 اكتوبر
يعني من حوالي 11 12 يوم ولكنها لم تقدم
على الغزو البري حتى الان لان ان في
صعوبات كتيره في عمليه الغزو واحد انت
عندك بشكل مباشر عندك حوالي اكثر من 200
اسير اسرائيلي فمصيرهم بدا في البدايه ان
اسرائيل غير مهتمه بهم لكن الان مع الضغط
الراي العام داخل اسرائيل هؤلاء محل
اهتمام عمليه بريه مع استمرار القذف من
شانه ان يعرض هؤلاء لمزيد من الخطر
اثنين
الدول اللي كانت وعلى راسها الولايات
المتحده اعطت اسرائيل ضوءا اخضرا بان
يذهبوا للعمليه البريه لما شافوا حجم
الخسائر الماهوله ولما طالت فتره القذف
ولما ادركوا ان اسرائيل لا ترغبوا فقط في
الانتقام من جماعه حماس التي تعتبرها بعض
الدول الغربيه جماعه ارهابيه او على الاقل
لا يتعاطفون معها بداوا يغيرون رايهم
بالتدريج يعيدون النظر في الجرين كارد
الذي كانوا منحوه للاسرائيليين والسبب
الثالث ببساطه انه اسرائيل بدات تدرك انه
العمليه مهوله جدا قد تستغرق وقتا طويلا
بعض المسؤولين الاسرائيليين كانوا سربوا
معلومات يعني لصحف كبيره وقالوا ان
العمليه عشان تحقق هدفها المعلن وهو
استئصال جماعه حماس قد يستغرق سنوات
وخسائر ضخمه فكل ده بيخليهم يترددوا ده
احنا كده نتكلم على ايه عشان السؤال يكون
متكرر ليه هم مترددين اما العواقب فدي بقى
قصه هنتكلم عنها طول البث ان شاء الله لكن
في سطور قليله واحد خسائر ضخمه جدا لا
نتمنى ان تكون ابدا في الجانب الفلسطيني
اثنين العواقب هتتوقف نجاح ام فشل يعني
اذا نجحت اسرائيل في ان هي تحقق هدفها
المعلن هتبقى في مشاكل واذا فشلت هتكون في
في مشاكل اذا فشلت اسرائيل فطبعا واضح ان
هيكون في انتصار للمقاومه وهي علو شان
حماس وشان الجهاد
واسرائيل هتحدف فيها عمليه انسحاب زي ما
انسحبت الولايات المتحده من افغانستان
تنهار الحكومه تحدث ارتباك في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يعني امور كثيره على الجانب
الفلسطيني هتبقى السلطه الفلسطينيه سوف
تضعف لانه عندنا السلطه عندنا حماس كلاهما
بيمثل طيار
مختلفا قد يتعزز الانقسام ربما السلطه
الفلسطينيه كلها يعني تتعرض الى هزه كبيره
لا تقوم منها هي في وضع ضعيف
ا هيكون في اضطراب في العالم العربي لان
في دول عربيه كثيره وان ابدت تعاطفها لكن
كانت تتمنى ان تكون حماس منتصره اذا
انتصرت اسرائيل بمعنى ان حققه اهدافها
فيترتب على ده امور كثيره جدا لا يتخيلها
احد منها على سبيل المثال ان اسرائيل سوف
تكون او سوف تغرق في
مستنقع الضفه اسف قطاع غزه اللي انا
هكلمكم عنه بعد شويه علشان الاجابه لا
تطول اكثر من اللازم
يعني لكن يعني اكيد هتسال عليه مرحبا
استاذ
سيد طه اشكرك السلام
عليكم عطره تلاوات عطره اهلا وسهلا عبد
الله عمو سيد شكرا لك ربنا يخليك حبيب
قلبي عبد الله مساء الخير استاذ سيد
ترمنيتر عليكم السلام السلام عليكم انت
اكثر صحفي محترم اشكرك حسام لا اتوقع ان
تسقط خلفها
امريكا تسقط فين امريكا فيها مشاكل تكفيها
من غير اسرائيل ج
دود هل اللي صار حركه مفتعله من ايران
لنقل الشعب الفلسطيني انا عاوز اقول
حضراتكم طبعا
هو يعني واحنا عملنا حلقه عن نظريه
المؤامره في مساله غزه وقبل كده انا كنت
مهتم بنظريه المؤامره لو كتبتوا كلمه
المؤامره على القناه ممكن يعني تجدوا
بعض ضالتكم فيها يعني انما انا عندي يعني
رجاء انه اي معلومه كمبدا عام اذا يعني
اذا جاز لي ان انا اعطي نصيحه ان
المعلومات اللي لا يتوفر علي
دلائل قويه وبل معلومات يعني مافيش داعي
لطرحها بهذه الثقه يعني لانه اللي بيقول
انه حركه مفتعله من ايران لقتل الشعب
الفلسطيني ايران تستفيد ايه من قتل الشعب
الفلسطيني ايران ليس لها مشكله مع الشعب
الفلسطيني انت تقصد ممكن انه هل ايران
لعبت دور في ان هي تشجع حماس على هذه
الخطوه حتى تمارس ضغطا على اسرائيل
وامريكا ق قد يبدو ذلك منطقيا لكن ايضا
ليس لنا على ذلك دليل كل اللي عندنا من
معلومات ان ايران لديها علاقات جيده بحماس
هل هذه العلاقات ترقى الى الحد اللي هي
تقنع بها قاده حماس ان يضحوا بانفسهم كلام
مش منطقي على العموم الاجابه لا واذا
اردتم مزيد ارجعوا لحلقه لماذا يعتقد
البعض ان طوفان الاقصى ليست الا تمثيليه
من اخراج اسرائيل واستضاف الدكتور احمد
يوسف وفيها تفاصيل كثيره يسعد مساك دكتور
مع تعديل صغير انا صحفي ولست دكتور فالله
يسعد مساك هل ستتراجع الدول العربيه عن
التطبيع بدر ابتلي ن لا تراجع عن التطبيع
ولكن هناك هناك توقف لكن فكره ان تتراجع
الدول عن التطبيع امر صعب الا اذا سء
الامور الى حد اللي انا تصوره ابدا بقى
ولا قدر الله واشتعلت حروب يعني
ربما واخيرا لقطك ليه واحنا ما كناش
ظاهرين عندك في اللايف اهلا وسهلا شو راح
يصير في غزه هل مصر راح
تدخل ما ده
سؤال صديقنا الزامل او الزميل يا صديقنا
احنا هنا بنتكلم على سيناريوهات مفتوحه
ولكن انا كنت بتكلم من شويه على
السيناريوهات الخطيره لو نجحت اسرائيل ما
احنا عندنا احتمالين يا اما اسرائيل تفشل
يا اما اسرائيل تنجح ومعيار الفشل والنجاح
باختصار ان هي تحقق هدفها هدفها المعلن
على الاقل ان هي تقضي على حركه حماس اذا
فشلت فاحنا تكلمنا ان ده هيكون لي
ارتدادات عنيفه جدا على الاسرائيليين
وارتدادات عنيفه على السلطه الفلسطينيه
وصعود لحركه حماس وصعود لحركه الجهاد ودعم
كبير جدا
ليران ودعم جدا ل حزب الله يعني هيكون ليه
ارتدادات على المنطقه
كلها
انما اذا فشل اذا نجحت بقى اسرائيل والحقت
قدر كبير جدا من الضرر للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه فده هيكون ليه اضرار على
اسرائيل اكثر مما لو فشلت او على الاقل
بنفس القدر لانه اسرائيل هربت من غزه في
2005 لما انسحبت في عهد ايرل شارون لاسباب
شرحها ولكن باختصار قطاع غزه كان كابوسا
للاسرائيليين ليس فيه ثروات لا يمثل يعني
مصلحه قوميه كبيره مشاكله لا تنتهي خسائر
الاسرائيليه في فادحه قطاع حجمه صغير جدا
زي محافظه في اي دوله يعني من الحجم
المتوسط عدد سكار بتتكلم على حوالي 2
مليون و300 فكث افه كبيره جدا يعني خصوصا
ان في اماكن كثيره فيه ليست يعني ما هوله
وبالتالي هم عاوزين يهربوا منه علشان تخرج
تسقط حماس لازم ما في ما انت ما فيش منطقه
في هذا العالم تكون ثقب اسود يعني ايه ثقب
اسود يعني منطقه فيها سكان بشر مجتمع بشري
وفي نفس الوقت لا توجد فيه سلطه لازم تكون
سلطه طيب اذا سقطت حماس من سيحكم القطاع
فكره ان تاتي السلطه الفلسطينيه مساله
عليها علامات استفهام كتيره نفترض ان هي
نجحت ودت بالسلطه الفلسطينيه هنا يكون في
سؤال مطروح بقوه على الجانب الاسرائيلي
بعد شويه انتم كنتم موقفين عمليه السلام
لانه ما فيش طرف تثقوا فيه لانه في سلطتين
انتم كنتوا موقفين عمليه السلام لانه
جماعات المقاومه بتهدد فاذا جاءت السلطه
اللي هي ا بتتبنى سياسه السلام وحل
الدولتين كيف يمكن ان تتنصل اسرائيل من حل
الدولتين ساعتها مش هتجد حل الا ان ان هي
تشجع على قيام جماعات مقاومه اخرى او
اعذار او تسقط السلطه الفلسطينيه او تشجع
الخلافات فيما بينهم يعني فهتبقى مشكله
كبيره بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه طبعا انا
ما بتكلمش على المقاس اللي بيتعرض لها
الفلسطينيين لان هذا موجود للاسف في كل
السيناريوهات هذا امر مقطوع به ولا حيله
لنا فيه يعني غير الدعاء
ا حكايه دخول مصر بقى دي قصه تانيه انت
مصر اولا كانت بتحكم قطاع غزه من سنه 49 ل
67 ثم بعد هزيمه 67 احتلت غزه واحتلت
سيناء وبعد كده جاء انتصار 73 وتحررت
سيناء جزء منها بقوه السلاح وجزء منها
بالمفاوضات وظلت غزه تحت الاحتلال الى ان
خرجت في 2005 زي ما زي ما حضراتكم زي ما
قلت لحضراتكم مصر لا ترغب ابدا ابدا ابدا
في ان يكون لها علاقه بقطاع غزه
ده عبق كبير عامله زي المثل الانجليزي
الهود بوتيتو ولا مش عارف المثل الفرنساوي
انه ده زي البطاطا السخنه اللي كل واحد
بيرميها للثاني افضل حل لمصر ان يكون قطاع
غزه مستقر هادئ مرحب بسكانه حتى لا تنزح
المشكله اليها لكن اذا ساءت الامور فمصر
ما تقدرش تبعد كتير عن المشكله وسوف تكون
في مواجهه ليس مع قطاع غزه كمشكله ولكن
كمان مع الاسرائيليين ودي قصه كنا بنتحدى
سيناريوهات بعيده تصريحات المسؤولين وعلى
راسهم رئيس الدوله بتقول ان ده مش احتمال
بعيد ولا
حاجه احتماليه تطور الحرب الى حرب اقليميه
بنظرك ده انس انا الاول عليكم السلام ده
اخونا
ا سامحوني مش عارف اقرا الاسامي يا ريت
تكتبوها بالعربي عشان انا احب ادعوكم
باسمائكم يعني احتمالات التطور ده انس
احتمالات تطور الحرب على السنه اكبر
السياسيين في العالم ليست احتمالا بعيدا
انا ليه بقول اكبر السياسيين في العالم
لانه ممكن بعض الصحف تخلق حاله كده من
المبالغات ممكن بعض الناس اللي هم بيسموهم
ورست كي ساروز انالست المحللين اللي دايما
بيرسموا صوره سوداء لا بعيدا عن هؤلاء
مسؤولين كبار في روسيا في الصين في ايران
في مصر في الاردن في كل حته في الولايات
المتحده بيقولوا ان هذا سيناريو وارد
جدا انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه
يعني في سيناريو يعني ناس كتيره مش بتتكلم
عنه ربما تكون كل الاطراف كل الاطراف يعني
الدول والجماعات الدول ديت يعني مصر
واسرائيل
و دول الخليج وايران وتركيا والولايات
المتحده وكل دول لا يرغبوا في الحرب وتكون
كل الاطراف الغير دول زي حزب الله زي قسام
زي الجهاد كله غير راغب في انه يعني يصعد
المساله ومع ذلك تقع الحرب ببساطه لانه
بمجرد ما بتقترب القوات والحشود بيتخلق
منطق تاني اسرائيل جندت او استدعت يعني
اكتر من 350 ال مجند رقم غير مسبوق حماس
بتستعد بعشرات الالاف هي والجد بعشرات
الالاف من المقاتلين حزب الله متاهب
الولايات المتحده بعتت طبعا زي ما كل
الناس عرفوا حاملات طائرات وبريطانيا
ماعرفش عليها الف علامه استفهام كالعاده
هذه البريطانيا بعدت بوارج وسفن حربيه الى
اخره كله مستعد في الاجواء دي مهما كانت
رغبتك في انك انت تمارس ضبط النفس قد
تنفلت الامور ببساطه لحاجه من اثنين سو
تقدير ممكن يحصل سوء تقدير يعني حد ارى
نيه حد غلط او انه الجامعات المنفلت يعني
ايه الجماعات المنفلت في كلمه مشهوره
لكندي الرئيس كيندي في اثناء ازمه
الصواريخ في كوبا سنه 62 ازمه صواريخ كوبا
سنه 62 اللي كانت اقرب لحظه كانت ممكن
تندلع فيها حرب عالميه ثالثه يعني بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه كان ليه كلمه
سامحوني يعني انه يقوللك ذز
دايما هناك عشان ما اقولش الكلمه اللي مش
مناسبه يعني دايما
هناك هو قال
كده دايما في واحد غبي مغفل من القوات من
العسكريين دايما غايب او ما وصلتش
التعليمات فعمل تصرف ممكن تتقلب الدنيا
الكلام ده ممكن يتطبق ازاي حزب الله مسيطر
على كل قواته و دي تعليمات ما حدش يضرب
ضربه لاسرائيل تادي لاستفزازه بالكامل
واسرائيل مديه لكل قوتها على الارض وحماس
كل لكن في حد ما وصلوش المعلومه لاي سبب
في حد اساء فهم التعليمات فضرب ضربه صعب
جدا لاسرائيل ان تتجاهلها او بالعكس تندلع
الحرب فتلاقي ان كل الاطراف ديت غارقه في
حرب اقليميه تحيه من بوستن ربنا يخليك
اشكرك هل من مصلحه المنطقه قيام حرب شامله
لا ما فيش اي مصلحه في قيام حرب شامله
مافيش من مصلحه اي حد ان تقوم حرب شامله
ولا اي طرف من هذه الاطراف مساء الخير
وخصوصا اصل انت علشان يكون لك مصلحه في
حرب اي طرف ليه مصلحه في حرب هي الحرب
اللي يقدر يبداها ويتحكم في مسارها وفي
نهايتها يبقى ل مصلحه في حرب لكن الحروب
اللي بتتعد اطرافها ومن بين الاطراف دي
بتبقى اطراف قويه محدش يتمناها
يعني احمد اهلا وسهلا
الجبوري بيقول يبدو ان الاقتحام قد طرب هل
يمكن ان توقف الدول العربيه النفط كما حدث
من
قبل والله سؤال سؤال صعب بصراحه لان في
الحاله ديت انت انت عندك اطراف مش بس
الدول العربيه انت عندك الدول العربيه
كدول منتجه للنفط وعندك ايران وعندك روسيا
وبالمناسبه رغم تباين المواقف لكن الاطراف
الثلاثه دول اقرب الى الموقف الفلسطيني مع
تباين المواقف العربيه الثلاثه دول اقرب
الى الموقف الفلسطيني من الموقف
الاسرائيلي الامريكي اللي هو بالنسبه لي
انا في غايه الاستفزاز يعني
ا
ف سؤال والله على حسب تطورات الاحداث
والحرب دي هيكون فيها مين يعني لكن وارد
ماهواش حاجه يعني لا تبدو لي غريبه جدا ما
سبب الدعم الامريكي للكتبه الاسرائيليه
بخصوص قصف المستشفى اسد ده اخونا اسد اسد
والله انا انا انا الحقيقه المشكله مش في
انه الامريكان
صدقوا الروايه الاسرائيليه المشكله
بالسرعه التي صدقوها انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك
على حاجه يا اخونا اسد انا من بعد يوم
سبعه او مانيه اندهشت جدا جدا من حاجه
يمكن علشان تحس بيه يمكن لو كانت خلفيتك
البانيه زي حالاتي كده صحفي يعني احنا
بنتعلم ايه بنتعلم ان لما يجيلنا خبر
واحنا بنتعلم في اول المهنه لازم تتيقن
منه بكل السبل الممكنه تتيقن منه ازاي اول
حاجه تمرر على العقل يعني في اخبار مش
منطقيه ابدا ابدا
يعني فلازم انت تمرره على العقل اثنين
لازم تسال على الاقل لان في سرعه على
الاقل مصدرين مختلفين فذي فيفاي او يؤكد
لك
المعلومه وتناقش التفاصيل انت عندك في يوم
يه ويوم تسعه ظهر علينا الاسرائيليين بخبر
غريب جدا انه القوات الحمساويه قوات
النخبه الكوماندوز الحمساوي عمل مجموعه من
الاشياء خلاف ان هو عمليه التفان الاقصى
انه قطع رؤوس مواطنين اسرائيليين من
المستوطنين قطع رؤوس اثنين اغتصب سيدات
وباعداد كثيره ثلاثه قطع رؤوس من بين من
قطع رؤوسهم هم بيبز يعني رضع وكان بدايه
الروايه انه انه تم اغتصاب ردع ايضا بديه
خالص انا لما تسمع الخبر ده انا توقعت ان
مستحيل حد يصدقه انا كصحفي مش ان انا
متعاطف مش متعاطف انا بتكلم مهنيا يعني
لانه تخيل ان في قوات نخبه قوات كوماندوس
قوات خاصه دخ تنفذ
عمليه فلسطينيين او غير فلسطينيين في
اسرائيل او غير فلسطينيين انت لما تيجي
تحلل عمليه حماس هي في حقيقه الامر في
العلم العسكري اقرب الى سو صيد يعني شبه
انتحاريه لانه فرصه خروجك حي محدوده خصوصا
لو تاخرت في التوقيت فهل من الطبيعي انه
في الاجواء دي وفي المهمه اللي هي بتحارب
عدو اكبر منك بكثير وعنصر الوقت فعال هو
داخل يغتصب سيدات طيب لو افترض والاغرب من
كده انه يقتل بيبي والاغرب والاغرب انه
يغتصب بيبي هل ده الانسان الطبيعي مش ممكن
يعمل كده حتى لو مش في حرب فما بالك لو
كان عنصر الوقت والضغط عنده مهام اخرى ولو
افترضنا ان في حد فقد عقله وعمل اي حاجه
من التصرفات الثلاثه ديت يبقى بشكل جماعي
عدد كبير منهم فعل او تور ومع ذلك القصه
كلها تمناها الرئيس الامريكي ثم وزير
الخارجيه ثم عدد وافر من المسؤولين ولو
كلمتكم عن التفاصيل ممكن
اقدي بعد عده ايام ابت وبعض المذيعين في
على قنوات كبيره
المسؤول الاسرائيلي بيقول وهم يطقطقون
رؤوسهم بدون اي مسائله او دراسه للمساله
او تمحيص فيعني انت بتقول لي ليه صدقوا هم
صدقوا الروايه الاكثر غرابه
يعني انا انا عاوز استاذنكم تشوفوا حلقه
بعنوان لماذا يخاف الرؤساء الامريكان من
اسرائيل هي حلقه من حوالي سنه ونص ا بس هي
مش بالضبط يعني مش العنوان مركز على خوف
ولكن هو مركز على العلاقه الخاصه جدا وسبب
النفوذ الاسرائيلي على
ا على الولايات المتحده استاذنكم تشوفوها
ا انا اظن انه يعني انا راضي عن النتائج
اللي وصلت لها طبعا في اسباب تبدو بديهيه
لكن في اسباب ما تبدو بديهيه قوي ا لاسباب
الدعم الامريكي المطلق لاسرائيل استاذنكم
ده ممكن هيديكم اجابه ا اعمق شويه من
[موسيقى]
ا يعني الاسباب اللي بتتقال اعتبارات
انتخابيه تاثير الجاليه اليهوديه لا في
اسباب كمان اعمق ارجعوا للحلقه اللي هي
بهذا العنوان اللي اذكره بشكل
جيد ا هل اسرائيل غير مهتمه انها قد تدخل
في حرب مباشره مع مصر سمير لا مهتمه جدا
وتخشى جدا ولا ترغب في ذلك ولا تحلم بذلك
واعط مثالا من عده شهور في مجند مصري في
ظروف لم تكشف عنها السلطات المصريه
و لم تكشف عنها بشكل كبير السلطات
الاسرائيليه ولكن كشفت عنها الصحف
الاسرائيليه في كل الاحوال مجند مصري دخل
وقتل عدد من الجنود ده لو كان حصل على
الجبهه اللبنانيه مثلا كان ادى الى انه
اسرائيل تدخل وتضرب او يعني انما انت عندك
على طول خرج الجانب المصري
وا يعني استخدم لغه انه هذا لم يكن مقصودا
والجانب الاسرائيلي بقى الاغرب من كده انه
كان مصر على ان يستخدم لغه هادئه
وانه مصر دوله صديقه وانه اي تجاوز يعني
احنا فاهمين ان ده غير مقصود وانه هيتم
التحقيق بين السلطات لانه اخر ما تتمناه
اسرائيل ان تفتح جبهه مع دوله عربيه جديده
خاصه اذا كانت دوله بحجم
مصر ونتمنى ان ده ما
يحصلش السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اللهم احمي
الاردن ومصر من كيد المعتدين عدي عمري
واللهم احيا الجميع يا صديقي مش بس مصر
والاردن امين ماذا سيحصل استاذ سيد اذا
اقتحم الفلسطينيون الاراضي المصريه بالسبب
الارهاب الصهيوني علي ابراهيم اذا حدث ذلك
فسوف يكون يعني يعني موقف ماساوي وكابوس
للسلطات المصريه اللي هتكون بين خيارات
صعبه جدا جدا جدا
الخيار الاولاني خلاص كل الناس بتتكلم
عليه
والرئيس المصر اتكلم عليه واتكلم عليه
بشكل يعني انا لم اعهده من مسؤولين كتير
في الفتره الاخيره ديت لما اوضح توابع
ماذا يعني ان يستجيب للطلب الامريكي
الاسرائيلي انا بتكلم على لساني بقى مش
بتكلم على لسان مسؤولين اللي هو بالغ
الاستفزاز بالغ السماجه بالغ يعني انه
يطلب من المصريين انه هم يفتحوا مش علشان
جرحه ولا حالات انسانيه لا عشان يستقبلوا
كل
القطاع بالنسبه لمصر ده معناها اذا وافقت
هيبقى يترتب عليه الاتي واحد طبعا السبب
اللي كل الناس عارفاه انه تم تفريغ خطق
غزه من سكان
وتخلصت اسرائيل من نف من نصف مشكله الدوله
الفلسطينيه انه ال
2300000 2 مليون و300 الف خلاص بقوا في
عهده دوله اخرى لمده قد ايه الى ان ننته
الكلام المعلن من مهمتنا المهمه اللي هي
ايه مهمه التخلص من حركات المقاومه على
راسها فلسطين والجهاد كم من الوقت وفقا
ليه هم افتحوا اكسيوس
الموقع امريكي اللي بيحقق
يعني يعني عنده صلات ومصادر جيده قالوا
ممكن قالوا للامريكان قد تستغرق سنوات
وماذا سوف يتم خلال هذه السنوات مطارده
مهمه مفتوحه في محاوله القضاء على حماس
وكان حماس ديت يعني مثلا خليه من خمسه سته
يخلصوا عليها
ثم تطهير كل القطاع من الانفاق اللي هو
شبكه ضخمه اعاده بنائها قصه ممكن تستغرق
سنين فده رقم واحد اثنين طبعا في هذه
الاثناء هيكون خلاص بقت في حياه اخرى
وفلسطينيين ده اذا تم يعني موجودين على
فلسطين في سيناء او في غيرها من المدن
ويكون الاسرائيليين
كده يعني ارتاحوا تماما من نصف المشكله
اثنين هيترتب عليه وده اللي بيقولوا
مسؤولين مصريين وقالوا الرئيس المصري على
الهواء ان معنى كده طب ما انت هيجي هنا
الفلسطينيين اللي هيجي هنا مش كلهم يعني
امهات عايزين يودوا اولادهم المدرسه و وا
يعني لا او مدرس عاوز يشتغل او دكتور عاوز
لا انت بتتكلم في بنفس جماعات المقاومه دي
بدل ما كانت بتقاوم من غزه هتقاوم من
سيناء وتنطلق العمليات من سيناء وترد
عليها القوات الاسرائيليه في سيناء فترد
القوات المصريه على القوات الاسرائيليه
وتصبح حربا او مواجهه عسكريه خامسه
ا فلا المساله بالغه الخطوره وطبعا اذا
حدث ذلك ونجحت السلطات الاسرائيليه في ذلك
فما المانع ان تكرر ذلك في
في
فلسطيني الضفه حيث يذهبون بقى الى الاردن
او
غيرها انت حضرتك بنرجع تاني ده ده ده ده
ده الكابوس الاولاني بكل ابعاده الكابوس
الثاني انه لو قدر الله تنض اسرائيل في
هذا السيناريو المرعب وتجد مصر نفسها
السلطات المصريه ان في مئات الالاف في وضع
صعب لا يمكن ابدا ان تتركهم يعني كده
للموت
وال والقصف الهاج ده فتبقى انت اذا اغلقت
ابوابك هتبقى ضغط عنيف جدا على السلطات
المصريه ا
ف يعني الاجابه صعبه الخيار صعب الحلول
صعبه افضل حل في هذه المسائل انه ماوصلش
ابدا لهذه المرحله بكل السبل وقف العمليه
القذف ضروري
جدا المساعدات لازم تروح باسرع وقت ممكن
وده عاوز جهد يتجاوز قدره مصر على الضغط
عاوز كل الدول العربيه عاوز مصر وعاوز
الجزائر وعاوز الاردن وعاوز الخليج وعاوز
المغرب وعاوز كل الدول بالاضافه لتركيا
وايران كل العالم
يعني كيف تستفيد الولايات المتحده من
الدعم بالاسلحه طالما انها لا تاخذ
مقابلها اموالا من اوكرانيا او اسرائيل
اظنك يا عمر بتتكلم عن حال الدكتور جود
عبد الخالق قبل ما اجاوب على سؤالك
استاذنكم حلقه الدكتور جود عبد
الخالق هي 30 دقيقه انا
اظنها
تلخيص لسنين من الجهد مش من الدكتور جوده
ولكن لمن يريد ان يفهم محتوى الح الحلقه
يعني انه تفهم انه يشرح لك طبيعه النظام
الراس مالي انه يلخص لك افكار راس ماليه
وكينز واقطاب انه يلخص لك بعض افكار من
كارل ماركس انه يلخص لك ازمه النظام
العالمي اسباب الازمات المتكرره اسباب
الخلل في الثروات في العالم الحقيقه حلقه
قد تكون دسمه اكثر من اللازم لبعض اللي ما
عندهمش خلفيه ولكن اذا صبر 30 دقيقه اعتقد
سواء اتفقت ام اختلفت هي تختصر لك سنوات
من القراءه والاطلاع اعود الى سؤال حضرتك
طبعا هي الحلقه الاخيره اظنها هي الحلقه
الاخيره اللي
هي الايدي الخفيه التي تدق الحروب وازاي
تستخدم الحروب لانقاذ الاقتصادات الزومه
ارجعوا للحلقه علشان لا اكرر ما جاء
فيها ازاي بتستفيد لا الولايات المتحده
بتدفع الولايات
المتحده
بتدفع يعني اولا هي الشركات لما بتنتج
الشركات لا تعطي مجانا الحكومه بتشتري
وبتعطي او الجيش الامريكي بيشتري وبعدين
بيبيع هذه الاسلحه لدول اذا ما باعش بيحصل
على اهداف اخرى يعني اذا ما بعش
الاوكرانيا على سبيل المثال فهو بيحقق هدف
استراتيجي اخر بعيدا عن مبيعات السلاح
المباشره احنا عندنا الصوت ده جاي منين يا
ج لا تقريبا حد بره ولا حاجه في الاستديو
اللي بره فهو بيستفيد يعني مثلا اذا اعطى
اسلحه الشركات بتستفيد
اللي بيخسر مين اللي بيخسر دافع الضرائب
الامريكي الذي مول المشتريات اللي حصلت
الشركات الامريكيه على اسلاح الشركات اللي
بينتج السلاح مين مش الحكومه الامريكيه
اللي بينتج السلاح شركات شركات عملاقه
بيشتريها الجيش الامريكي والجيش الامريكي
يا بيستخدمها يا بيعطيها
لدول حليفه لكن الشركات بتبيع في كل
الاحوال وبتحصل على ارباحها سواء من الجيش
الامريكي او من بيعها بعد ابن السلطات
الامريكيه لجيوش اخرى لما الجيش الامريكي
او الحكومه الامريكيه تعطي سلاحا لا
تتقاضاه في شكل مساعدات بيكون ده لاسباب
تتعلق باهدافه الاستراتيجيه زي ان هو
يستنزف الروس زي ان هو يدعم الاسرائيل الى
الابد ا الاسباب اللي بتتقال في الكونجرس
انا بحافظ على حليف انا بحافظ على مصالحي
انا بحارب جماعات ارهابيه الى اخره
فالشركات مستفيده في كل الاحوال ودفع
الضرائب امريكي متضرر في كل
الاحوال كل الحب لك من سوريا موالاه
ومعارضه ربنا يخليك ام ار شكرا جزيلا ليك
والله ما هدف الولايات المتحده من اشعال
فتيل الحرب في كثير من المناطق احمد
ا
احمد مش عارف اقرا الاسم الثاني
لكن الهدف زي ما قلت لحضرتك مجموعه من
الاهداف اشعال الحروب واحد انه انا ده
دولا عاوزه انا يعني رئيس مجلس اداره
العالم وعلي ان اتاكد من تنفيذ مصالحي كيف
تنفذ مصالحك زي ما كان الدكتور احمد يوسف
احمد بيقول لكم في حلقه قريبه في الحوارات
الاخيره اللي عملتها العلاقات الدوليه
كلها عبار عن مصالح وقوه كل واحد عنده
مصالح عاوز ينفذها وقدر من القوه وبتنفس
مصالحك بقدر ما تملك من قوه قوه الولايات
المتحده متعدده
المستويات قوه ان هي قوه ماليه انها تمنحك
مساعدات او تعطيك مساعدات انها تسمح لك
بالاقتراض من صندوق النقد والبنك الدولي
ان هي تسمح لك بانك تعبر عن وجهه نظرك في
الامم المتحده في مجلس الامن مستويات
المتعدده ومن بين هذه المستويات طبعا
العقوبات الماليه وغيرها ومن بين هذه
المستويات انها تستخدم السلاح علشان تحقق
مصالحها بانها تجبرك على ما تريد هي
بتستفيد ايه من الحروب اشعال حروب هي
مالهاش مصلحه فيها مباشره
من بين الاسباب الواضحه جدا السبب
الاقتصادي لما تهد دوله وتعيد بناها بتاخد
فلوس طب عاوزين مثال على كده المثال مش
بعيد ولا حاجه شوفوا اللي حصل في 2000 اخر
و22 اه اخر 2011 2012 الدول
الاوروبيه بدعم ومباركه من الولايات
المتحده شنت هجوم على ليبيا الهدف المعلل
ليه هو حمايه المعارضه من عدوان ذا في
طبعا في 1ف تفاصيل في الوسط يعني عاوز
علامات استفهام بس ده يطول شرحه لكن في
النهايه لو افترضنا ان هي كان ده الهدف
وان الهدف ده باركته مجلس الامن لان مجلس
الامن ما قالش كده بالضبط وده اغضب الروس
كثيرا يعني واغضب دول عربيه اخرى او دول
اخرى في العالم لكن هن تجاوز كل ده لان في
تفاصيل كثيره انت عاوز تقلص او عاوز تضعف
القوات الدوله او قوات القذافي
وتنقذ الم معارضه لماذا تضرب محطات المياه
ومحطات الغاز
وتضرب مدارس وتضرب شبكه طرق ليه التفسير
الواضح انه يعني مافيش تفسير تاني انت كان
ممكن تضرب الدفاعات الجويه كان ممكن تضرب
مخازن السلاح لكن ضرب ده وضرب ده على اساس
انه الحكومه التي كانوا ياملون ان تاتي
ويعني ده ما تحقق لكن ليس بالقدر الكافي
تشتري منهم اسلحه بدل التي تم تدميرها
وتستعين بش هم لاعاده بناء المدارس
والانفاق ومحطات المياه والكهرباء والغاز
وهكذا هذا هو السبب وطبعا في سبب تاني انه
احيانا بتبقى عاوزه تعمل تضغط على دوله
اخرى ما انت لما تضرب دوله مثلا مثلا لما
اكون متواجد في سوريا فانت بتحاول تمارس
ضغوط على ايران وعلى
روسيا
اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ سيد ربنا يخليك ذو
الفقار حدثنا عن افاق المفاوضات الجاريه
الجاريه فين بقى تقصد في ما يتعلق بازمه
في الاراضي المحتله العالم كله بيتفاعل
كله ولكن احنا
قدام اسرائيل وحلفها الولايات المتحده
بالدرجه الاولى وعدد من الدول الغربيه اقل
شويه مما بدا في البدايه في جانب وعندك
بقيه او كثير من الدول الاخرى في جانب اخ
اخر لانه المنطق مش قادر يوصل لاسرائيل
طبعا ومش قادر للولايات المتحده انه احنا
انتم مركزين على
انه حماس جماعه ارهابيه وقتلت ابرياء
ماحدش بيقول ابدا ان الابرياء دول يعني هم
جماعات استيطان على اراضي غيرهم يعني وانه
هذه الجماعات الاستيطانيه هي عائق اساسي
للسلام يعني ولكن دي قصه يطول شرحها ومع
ذلك في كل الاحوال ماحدش قادر يجاوب على
السؤال السؤال الاخير لو لم تفعل ذلك حماس
هل اهالي غزه هيكونوا في وضع احسن هل كان
الاسرائيليين هيفك الحصار العملي المفروض
على غزه اللي هي سجد كبير هل احوال
الفلسطينيين هتتحسن هل الاحتلال سوف يزول
من يعني من محيط غزه اللي هو مستمر يعني
من 67 الى الان رغم ان هو خرج من من
القطاع نفسه ولكن في المستوطنات القريبه
وغزه اللي خرجوا منها يحاصرها من كل اتجاه
والخروج والدخول والعمل يبدو كانه في حاله
سجن دائم دايما محتاج اذن ودائما محتاج
فكل ده يعني الفكره الاساسيه واضحه للكل
ومفهومه للكل ولكن اسرائيل بقى والعلاقات
مع الولايات المتحده ببساطه الاسرائيليين
ما عندهمش استعداد انه يتخلوا عن شبر واحد
بيستمتع به مستوطن اسرائيلي الاعتبارات
ادفه بكثير جدا مما يتخيل البعض لانه
مستمتع وهو بيمثل صوت في الانتخابات
الامريكيه
اضف الى كل ذلك ان ما فيش تبعات لعدوانه
على اراضي غيره لانه هم بلد عنده اسلحه
ضخمه جدا قادر يحارب بها كل دول المنطقه
تقريبا من ح نظريا على الورق العمليه
الاخيره بتثبت انه هم اضعف من ذلك بكثير
وفي نفس الوقت اغنياء جدا جدا جدا جدا
دوله
يعني نصيب الفرد فيها من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي اللي بيتجاوز 500 مليار دولار
بتتكلم على حوالي 55000 دولار في السنه
ف يعني ما عندوش اي استعداد انه يتنازل عن
كل هذه
المزايا هل تظن يا استاذ سيد ان دخول
المساعدات دي ممكن تكون فخ الوقوع مصر في
فخ الحرب داخل غزه لا ده مصر احسها ده
محمد ده مصر اصرارها على دخول المساعدات
من جانبها ومن الدول اللي عاوزه تخ
تعبر المعبر بي مصر هي بتجيب مساعدات هي
من عندها وفي نفس الوقت من اراضيها بتمر
بمساعدات تركيه وسعوديه واماراتيه
وجزائريه وكل العالم يعني اللي عاوز يقدم
مساعدات هي من مصلحه مصر ان هي تخش تدخل
تدخل هذه المساعدات
مصر هي اللي بتصر عليها على اساس انه تسعى
الاستراتيجيه لوقف الضرب من ناحيه هي مش
قادره تمنع تعمل ده وادخال المساعدات
علشان تخفف المعاناه وفي الحاله دي يبقى
في عمليه اجهاض للمخطط الاسرائيلي ان هم
يبقى يبقى في قذف ومافيش مساعدات فما
يكونش
هناك طريق امام الفلسطينيين الا بالخروج
والضغط على الحدود
المصريه اما ان هي تتورد في حرب لدخول
المساعدات هي تتورد في حرب لو ان
المساعدات لم تدخل واضطر اهالي غزه ان
ياتوا ارين الى سيناء ويبقى قدامها خيارين
في منتهى السوء الخيار الاول ان هي تمنع
هذا العدد الضخم وتبقى متورطه في مواجهه
مع الفلسطينيين اللي هي لا تتمنى ابدا ان
تلحق بهم اد والخيار الثاني انه هي تضطر
تشتبك مع
الاسرائيليين هل ستتراجع الدول الع ا هل
ستتراجع الدول العربيه عن التطبيع تقديري
لا قد يتاجل المساله قد تعرقل لبعض الوقت
لكن لا
يعني يعني الاسباب الجوهريه الا اذا حصلت
تغييرات جوهريه كبيره بقى لان انت بتتكلم
على طموح
اسرائيلي مخيف بس انا مش عارف الطموح
الاسرائيلي ده مرتبط بمين انا اشك ان هو
مرتبط
بالساس الاسرائيليين كلهم لان كثير منهم
عقلاء تحبهم تكرههم انما الحكومه الحاليه
حكومه
استثنائيه في تطرفها وفي ضيق الافق يعني
انت لما تيجي تشوف ايه اهداف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه احنا احيانا بنقع في فخ تحليل
تصرفات السياسيين في دوله على انها بتمثل
المصالح القوميه لدوله ما المصالح القوميه
ديت يعني ايه او مصالح الامن القومي يعني
بتبص ل جغرافيتها بتبص لاقتصادها بتبص
بتشوف مطالب شعبها وبتبتدي تحلل انما في
جانب مهم جدا مصالح النخب انت هنا النخب
اللي
بتحكم العنصر الاساسي اللي بيحرك نتنياهو
حاجتين في حاجات اساسيه قبل ده يعني ان هو
كاره للفلسطينيين ده مش انا اللي بقول ده
كتير جدا من اللي يعرفوه وبما فيهم اوباما
نفسه في مذكراته ان هو كاره للفلسطينيين
وعنده قصه مشهوره وقتل اخيه في اظن في 74
و يعني ليه قصه كده
نتنياهو ف بس دي حاجات قديمه انا بتكلم في
الحاله دي واحد اللي
بيحركوا امرين اساسيين في الفتره الاخيره
انه لازم يبقى في
السلطه ابقى في السلطه ديت لانه اذا اذا
خرج من السلطه فهو ملاحق بع الاقل ثلاث
تهم او ثلاث كاتيجري من التهم تلقي به في
السجن وهو عنده 71 سنه هتلقي به في السجن
الى ان تنتهي حياته المهنيه على الاقل فطب
واذا بقى في السلطه القانون ما بيمنع انه
مسؤول في اسرائيل يحاكم لكن هو كان حريص
ان يسيطر يبقى في السلطه ويسيطر على
الكنيست عشان يعدل القوانين التي يمكن ان
تلاحقه وبالتالي فهو متم سك بالسلطه لانها
مساله حياه او موت بالنسبه له عشان يبقى
في السلطه تحالف مع مجموعه كان يرى انه ما
له ما كان يجب ابدا ان يكونوا في السلطه
فتحارب مع بن غفير وسمور تش اذا كنت اذكر
اسمه يعني هؤلاء المتطرفين اللي هم
بيدافعوا عن مصالح مستوطنين وعن قناعتهم
شريده التطرف تجاه الفلسطينيين طيب دول
بتحرك هذه المصالح والقناعات المتطرفه
مصالح المستوطنين يعني ايه يعني بيت
ومزرعه ارض واخدهم ما عندوش استعداد يسمهم
ابدا وبعض المسؤولين غير نتنياهو ايضا
ملاحقين في القضاء والسلطه بتحميهم فدول
عاوزين يبقوا عشان يبقوا مضطرين اولا
يشغلوا الراي العام الفلسطيني بصفه عامه
عن الراي العام الاسرائيلي عن عن
مطالب قطاع كبير منهم للحكومه بان ترحل
وكمان هم بيحرك الرغبه الغضب والشعور
بالاهانه والهز ما ف عاوزين ينتقموا
ويعيدوا الهيبه الاسرائيليه التي تعني
بالنسبه لهم الكثير اذا توقف العرب اذا
توقف خصوم اسرائيل عن الخوف من اسرائيل لن
تبقى اسرائيل كثيرا اسرائيل بتعتمد في
سياستها في الردع على تبني صوره عظيمه جدا
على ان هي
ا قوه لا تقهر انا عايز استاذنكم انا اسف
ان انا اطلت في الاجابه على السؤال كان في
حلقه افتكرتها دلوقتي انا عملتها من حوالي
سنه ونص او سنتين عن كيف تج كيف يجند
الموساد على ما اذكر يعني عملائه عن طريق
شبكه نتفليكس يعني لو دورتم في القناه
على المساد نتفليكس هتلاقوا الحلقه بس
خلاصه الحلقه اللي بتثبت الايام بفضل الله
ان ما كانش ما كانش
كلام يعني مش مظبوط ان انا بقول انه
الافلام والدراما الاسرائيليه بتصور الاس
المخابرات الاسرائيليه بكل اجهزتها مساد
وغير مساد على انهم اجهزه خارقه وانا كنت
بدلل على ان الكلام ده مبالغ فيه جدا لان
هم عاجزين عن امرين وفشلوا فيه بشكل متكرر
ان هم غير قادرين على تقدير قدرات
المقاومه في قطاع غزه اللي هو كان محتل
لسنوات طويله من اسرائيل و كشفين ومراقبين
وعندهم في عملاء على الارض وكل شيء
وعاجزين عن تقدير قدره حزب الله
وامكانياته في جنوب لبنان ونما تحت سمعهم
وبصرهم بحيث اصبح قوه ردع ف على بعد
كيلومترات مش اقل من كيلومترات حدوده
شمالا وجنوبا هو عاجز فيهم فانت بتصور
نفسك ان انت قادر ان انت تعرف اللي بيحصل
في الكريملين وفي واشنطن وفي القاهره لكن
عاجز ان انت تعرف الناس اللي على حدودك
ارجعوا للحلقه عشان تعرفوا انه في مبالغه
كثيره جدا جدا يعني في تقدير قدرات
اسرائيل
اا ما هي توقعاتك ده محمود ما هي توقعاتك
للاحداث الحاليه وهل
سوف تنسى احداث اوكرانيا بسبب الاحداث
بالشرق وهل سوف وهل سوف تنسى احداث
اوكرانيا بسبب الاحداث بالشرق الاوسط وهل
سيبقى الوضع سيء على اقتصادات الدول الى
25 انت عندك مجموعه من ال يعني نقاط يا
محمود بالنسبه لاوكرانيا اه طبعا ده من
ضمن الاسباب اللي بتبهج بوتين كثيرا ان
هذه الازمه اللي مستمره من 7 اكتوبر ترتب
عنها مجموعه من الاخبار السعيده الى بوتين
وربما تظل الاخبار اكثر سعاده لو اتسع
النطاق وطالت الازمه لان ده يترتب عليه
انشغال العالم كثيرا والاعلام عما يجري في
اوكرانيا اللي كان بيمثل ضغط شديد جدا على
الجيش الروسي
ف ثانيا انه مع وجود دوله اخرى اهم
بالنسبه للغرب وهي اسرائيل والمطالب بدعم
جديد ليهم ربما ده يكون على حساب الدعم
الاوكراني خصوصا ان في حاله تململ من
الدعم المستمر لاوكرانيا بعشرات المليارات
من الدولارات ثم بقى
انه على
المستوى ال
اداره المعركه الدعائيه كل الكلام اللي
اتقال عن بوتين من والجيش الروسي من
الهمجيه وكذا دلوقتي هم المسؤولين بيقولوا
شوفوا اسرائيليين بيعملوا ايه والامريكان
بيدعو في ايه مقطع مثلا متداول لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بيقول ان قطع المياه
والكهرباء عن بعض القرى ومدن اوكرانيا عمل
بربري وهو الراجل بيدعم ان الاسرائيلين
اعملوا ده و بجرين كارد كامل منه يعني ف
وفي اسباب اخرى يعني حبيتوا نتكلم عليها
نتكلم عليها ان شاء الله في الحلقه ان من
مصلحه مش من مصلحه يعني من بين المزايا
اللي ممكن روسيا تستفيد منها ا اذا طل امد
الحرب ده يصب على الاقل في المدى المنظور
في مصلحه روسيا
طبعا موقف السعوديه ما انا اسف
يعني هربت كده ال ا انا بقول هربت انا كنت
واقف وبعدين ج ق الاسئله فحاول اوصل لها
لانه عشان هو كان
السؤال هو السؤال اللي انا كنت واقف عنده
والاسئله جريت بسرعه بيقول لي موقف
السعوديه بالتحديد اذا كنت ما قريتش الجزء
الثاني من السؤال هوصل له ان شاء الله
السعوديه موقفها انه هي كانت في
مفاوضات اتكلمنا عنها في ثلاث اربع حلقات
مع الاسرائيليين بواسطه امريكيه للتطبيع
مع اسرائيل في مقابل مجموعه من الطلبات
خرجت علينا
اخبار منسوبه الى
مسؤولين لم يتم تسميتهم ان وقف هذه
المفاوضات الى اجل غير مسمى اعتراضا على
ما يجري الموقف العلني السعودي هو ادانه
للاسرائيليين
وبالتالي الموقف المعلن على الاقل وما
نراه على الارض انه هو موقف يدين يدين
السلطات
الاحتلال ثم تم ترجمه ذلك في انه ولي
العهد مثلا كان لما جاه وزير
الخارجيه يعني كان اظن جا يوم يعني التقا
في اليوم الثاني لانه كل وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه اتكلمت على انتظار وزير خارجيه
الولايات المتحده لساعات طويله حتى يلقا
وي العهد فالوضع ماهواش
يعني انا كده رجعت الاسئله الى ان اعود
الى نفس
التسلسل مصر اصبحت دوله هشه ده محمد بيقول
غير قادره على حمايه امنها القومي ضرب
معبر رفح اربع مرات وعدم رد مصر ببيان فضح
فضع ضعفها يعني انا مش متاكد ان انا متفق
معاك في هذا لانه انت كنت عاوز الرد يكون
ايه ان هي ما هي بترد انت لما يكون
عندك يعني اصل مفهوم الرد ان هي تضربها
بالصواريخ يعني انا شفت حد من الناس اللي
هم ليهم وجود على يعني قنوات وكده
يعني يعني احنا بيكون الكلام اشيل دش انا
اسف يعني ما فيقول لك ازاي انه مش عارف حد
بعت لي المقطع يعني انه الناس ازاي مصر
تبقى دوله كبيره ويبعته اتوبيسات
بالمساعده فترفض اسرائيل فيعودوا طب انت
كنت متوقع ايه ان هم يضربوهم بالصواريخ
الول بتمارس نوع كتير من ضبط النفس وال
والانضباط لانه المسائل مش بالشكل ده يعني
انت بتمارس اللي بتقدر عليه بتقدر عليه
بتعمل ايه ان انت مصر على انه المساع ددخل
مصر على رفض سياسه التهجير مصر على انك
انت تتعاون مع الاردن والسعوديه والامارات
وكل والاطراف العربيه المختلفه والدول
الاوروبيه في انك تفشل هذا المخطط ده اللي
ممكن تعمله طب خلاف كده انا ما اعتقدش ان
هيساعد ل مصر ولا الفلسطينيين ولا غيره
يعني لكن اذا تجنبنا اللغه يعني في هذا
الموقف فاه في تراجع في نفوذ مصر الخارجي
انا ما عنديش خلاف في ده لان مصر منكفئ
على نفسها منذ 2011 والى الان تراجع
النفوذ المصري على ساحات كثيره مش محل
جدال لكن اللي محل جدال هو اللي حضرتك
بتستشهد بيه على انه علامات على ضعف نفوذ
مصر ده يعني مع وافر الاحترام وده رايي قد
اكون مخطئ
اميني ا استاذي هل تتوقع افول امريكا في
السنوات
القادمه اه اتوقع افول الولايات المتحده
ومش توقع يعني مبني على يعني قرايه الطالع
ولا قراءه
الفنجان يعني ولكن الشواهد بتقول ان
امريكا اللي كانت بتنفرج
بسلطه مطلقه على دول العالم بتتراجع
نفوذها وبتظهر دول اخرى
ا بتلعب ادوار مهمه في مناطقها وده بيؤثر
على قدره الولايات المتحده على ان تنفذ ما
تريد والمؤشرات لا تقع تحت حصر ولكن اديلك
حاجات بسيطه كده انت لما يعني ايه اللي
حصل يوم الاربعاء اللي فات كان المفروض
انه مصر وال السلطه الفلسطينيه وملك
الاردن يلتقوا بايدن مقابله الرئيس
الامريكي
كانت يعني لغايه المفروض لغايه دلوقتي
يعني يعني مش عاوز ابالغ واقول حلم يعني
ولكن امر بيسعى ليه كل رؤساء الدول لانه
ده يعني الكثير كل واحد عنده لسته طلبات
كبيره يريد ان يلتقي الرئيس الامريكي
علشان يعني يستجيب لاكبر عدد منها لما يجي
الرؤساء الثلاثه ابو ومازن والسيسي والملك
عبد الله يلغون
المقابله
ف يعني ده طبعا هم مش متوقعين كتير يعني
هم انه ادركوا انه مقابلته كل الحكايه ان
هي هتضعف شعبيتهم وتخضب شعوبهم عليهم من
ناحيه ومش هيستفيدوا كثيرا انما بغض النظر
عن
الاهداف ما ده برض
يعني ده كان صعب يحصل لما تكون الولايات
المتحده في اوجهه وطبعا تضيف بقى انه رفض
انه ياخدوا مكالمات من بعض زعماء دول
الخليج زي ما حصل مع بايدن في بدايه
ازمه
اوكرانيا تحيه لك استاذ سيد من اليمن ربنا
يخليك يا محمد فيصل السلام عليكم عمليه
طوفان الاقصى من صالح الدول التي تسعى
للتطبيع بحيث تكسب تنازلات من اسرائيل
وامريكا او العكس ما دي بتبقى سنارات
مفتوحه حبيبي
ده انا اسف برده مش عارف اقرا الاسم يعني
انما
ا اكتبوا الاسامي بالعربي جنب الاسم اللي
انت بتكتب منه يعني بقدر الامكان علشان
اعرف يعني اناديك باسمك ما دي بقى قصه
بتخضع لاعتبارات كتيره يعني الدول اللي
الطبع ما كانش تتمنى ان ده يحصل يعني
مصلحه الامارات ايه في انه تجد ان الدوله
اللي هي اقبلت على سلام ساخن معها اصبحت
دلوقتي عبقا عليها واصبح انه في حاله من
التململ من السياسه الاسرائيليه واصبح في
ضغط على الامارات الا تستقبل الاسرائيليين
واصبح محرج للامارات ان تظهر في صوره
واحده مع الاسرائيليين ليس لها مصلحه ا
انما تاخد منها تنازلات علشان تستمر
العلاقات يجوز يتوقف بقى على اصل
اسرائيل
اسرائيل اسرائيل ظاهره في التاريخ
يعني تثير الدهشه يعني
انه اسرائيل برغم كل الكلام اللي بيتقال
عن اهميت هي بدون الولايات المتحده
بالدرجه الاولى اهميتها تتراجع كثيرا جدا
جدا جدا كل الكلام اللي اتكتب انا مش
اتكتب يعني في صحف صغيره ولكن اتكتب في
دراسات محترمه انه الاسرائيليين اصحاب
تجربه عظيمه وان هم استطاعوا ان ينشؤ دوله
قميه اقتصاد متطور الكلام ده مين اللي
بتقوله هيل ينتن في مذكرات يعني مثار
اعجاب جورج بوش الابن ناس كتيره جدا
باعجاب عن التجربه الاسرائيليه انا في
تقديري انه اللي بيقول الكلام ده يعني
كلام يحتاج الى مراجعه وانه اسرائيل كل
الكلام اللي بيتقال عن تجربتها وقوتها كله
مرهون بدعم امريكي وغربي مطلق وبدون هذا
الدعم لا تستطيع ان تستمر كثيرا مش بتكلم
في حرب يعني لا تستطيع ان هي تستمر وتزدهر
كدوله يعني هي شغاله على
ا
يعني انبوب كده للحياه انه بمجرد ما تتعثر
هتجد على طول ماما امريكا تنقذها
يعني ا ما
حقيقه هذا الخبر وهل هذا سيناريو محتمل
كشف كشف مصدر خطه الولايات المتحده
والاحلال تشمل تهجير نصف سكان غزه لسيناء
والقضاء على حماس قائلا ان بيض سيعرض على
مصر تصفير ديونها مقابل الموافقه على
الخطه عاصم القصه دي بنسمعها من زمان جدا
وهي قصه لا تخلو من من صحه يعني فكره ما
انت ما انت عشان تعرض على مصر ان هي
تستقبل 2 مليون ولا 3 مليون ولا مليون ولا
هتوافق ليه ما لازم في مقابل يعني في كل
المرات اللي فاتت اذا كانت في انا معارفش
ان في المره دي ده طرح وتفاصيله يعني ولكن
طول الوقت كان ده المقابل
وبعدين الاسرائيليين اصل احيانا دمهم خفيف
يقول لهم انتوا انتوا مشكلتكم ايه انتوا
ليه رافضين الفلسطينيين يعني ما انتم
عندكم ملايين السوريين وملايين الليبيين
وملايين السودانيين جت على دول ما تاخدوهم
ومؤقتا يعني سنتين ثلاثه اربعه بالكتير
يعني فبقول لكم دمهم خفيف
يعني انما الفكره مين اللي هيوافق يعني
الفكره صفروا ديونها ولا خدوا ولا ادوها
10 اضعاف الفكره مين يقدر ياخد
القرار واهم لان احيانا برض الدول الكبيره
يعني بت بيبقى تبان ان كل شيء فيها مدروس
بس احيانا بيقولوا كلام بسيط يعني جدا
يعني هو بيتخيل ان طالما الدوله دي مافيش
فيها ديمقراطيه وانه الرئيس عنده صلاحيات
او الملك عنده صلاحيات شبه مطلقه يست يطيع
الرئيس المصري او غيره انه ياخد قرار
ويمضي عليه هذا غير صحيح بالمره الكلام ده
في قرارات هنا هناك بتاع يعني انما في
قرار بهذا الحجم هذا اكبر بكثير جدا من
صلاحيات رئيس او ملك دي مساله لا يمكن
ابدا ان يبقى من يتخذ هذا القرار في موقعه
او حرا لانه دي مساله خطيره يعني وبالتالي
لا صعب يعرضوا ديون ما يعرضو ديون دي
مساله لازم مش بس ما ينفعش انه مجلس او
برلمان بضغط من السلطه التنفيذيه يوافق ده
صعب صعب الامور المصريه اللي زي كده لازم
يكون في موافقه حقيقيه جنوين مقبوله لا
تؤدي لطلبات الاجتماعيه تطيح بالرئيس او
بالملك او بالحكومه دي مسائل
خطيره ثم انه حتى بعد كل ده في مخاوف يعني
حتى انت لغيت الديون ولا عملت ولا في
مخاوف امنيه يعني ما انا شرحت لحضرتك مين
اللي هيجي وهيقعد فين
وهتبقى شكل العلاقه ازاي مصير قطاع غزه
مصير الضفه لا لا لا مساله اكبر بكثير
عشان
ا صعب يعني صعب ان حد يوافق عليها زي ما
انت متخيل كده بجرد قلم او ان هو يعني لا
صعب كنت اتمنى الدعوه ما حقي كنت يعني ردا
على سؤالك التفاصيل دي قديمه ومطروح من
سنين طويله كونها تجدد مش هيكون غريب وكون
هترفض لن يكون جديد كنت اتمنى الدعوه
لعوده اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في غزه وعددهم
70% من سكان القطاع الى بيوتهم التي هجروا
منها سنه 48 يافا وحيفا وعكا واسدود
والمجدل طبعا عاليه يعني هذا ما
بس يعني هذه ده ده الشيء السليم والمنطقي
ولكن هل يمكن ان نشبه الدعم الامريكي
بريطاني لاسرائيل بالعدوان الثلاثي على
مصر بمعنى ان تكون هذه نهايه الامبراطوريه
الامريكيه كما كانت نهايه
بريطانيا والله يعني اذا بعدنا عن التشبيه
ده يا دكتور كريم لانه التشبيه دايما
هيحتاج ان انت تستدعي ما حدث و وتحاول
تقرا بالضبط الجاري دلوقتي ممكن يبقى مربك
شويه ولكن انا في تقديري يعني انه ابعد
بريطانيا بريطانيا يعني اوريدي ظروفها
صعبه ولكن الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل ربما
يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى نهايتها كقوه
احد اسباب نهايتها كقوه كبيره كما
كان حرب السويس سنه 56 نهايه ل امبراطوريه
البريطانيه كده ممكن اذا كان ده اللي
تقصده ممكن ودي قصه تحتاج الى تفاصيل وان
شاء الله انا يعني انا انا كنت بفكر في
حلقه بهذا المعنى برض من ضمن الحلقات
المؤجله من فتره طويله
وان شاء الله تخرج قريبا الى
حضراتكم الساعه كام يا جون انا معايا جون
عادل النهارده ما عرفتكش عليه زميلنا
الجديد متعدد المواهب ودايما يقوللي كله
تمام كل تمام واحان يورطني لكن لغايه
دلوقتي
مورتنيش صح يا جون انت خلصت على مندو على
عمرو
صح اما لو عرفوا ان البث المباشر نجح في
وجودك هيخلصوا
عليك
لماذا اوروبا تتبع تتبع لكل قرارات امريكا
حتى لو على حساب حكومتها وشعبها مثال على
ذلك اعدائهم لروسيا ومناصر اوكرانيا والتي
دمرت اقتصاد اوروبا وان عاشت اقتصاد
امريكا وسقطت حكومات كثيره في اوروبا
نتيجه لذلك سؤال جميل يا فؤاد والله بس هو
السبب يعني انه واحد انه دول اوروبا ليسوا
على قلب رجل واحد يعني في دول زي
مثلا زي مثلا بولندا زي الول اللي هي
دول لاتفيا
[موسيقى]
واستونيا في عدد من الدول هو مش مؤمن بانه
الاتحاد الاوروبي رغم ان هم دول في اعضاء
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو مش مقتنعين ان
لهم حياه بدون الولايات
المتحده يعني تكط لونج ستور الشرطه و
نختصرها انه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في دول
مقتنعه انه اذا اردت
ان ترفع السماعه علشان ا تحافظ يعني ما
انت ما ترنش على بروكسل او على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان تتواصل مع واشنطن صاحبه القول
الفصل كل القضايا في تناقضات بين دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي النتيجه انه نتيجه انه
ايمان بعض الدول الاوروبيه ان لازم يبقوا
على علاقات قويه بواشنطن اذا ارادوا
البقاء على قيد الحياه فبي خي ان الاجماع
الاوروبي دايما محل يعني خلاف ثم اضف الى
كده بقى ان هم عندهم مشاكل فيع مع روسيا
انما لو اتركوا الاوروبيين لوحدهم لقرارهم
يعني ما كانش طبعا ذهبوا الى هذا المذهب
المتطرف جدا جدا اللي بتقو الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا اللي مش متضررين كثيرا
اللي متضرر اكتر دول
المواجهه اوروبا الشرقيه ومعاهم المانيا
الى
اخره وعموما ده اللي بيحصل للدول اللي ما
عندهاش قدره تدافع عن نفسها هل قد تكون
روسيا خلف عمليه طوفان الاقصى يعني ما
اعتقدش ان عندها هذا القدر من النفوذ
والقوه ابدا ان هي
تحرك جماعه زي حماس العلاقه جيده بين حماس
وروسيا لكن العلاقات ايضا جيده بين روسيا
و واسرائيل 15% من الاسرائيليين بيتكل
اللغه الروسيه يا صديقي لان اصولهم من
روسيا ودول الاتحاد قريبه دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق مصر خمسه حروب ضد الغرب
من حرب 48 56 67 اه انت حسبت حرب
الاستنزاف و 73 اخي سيد الحرب اليوم في
غزه تشرح لماد السدات عمل اتفاق
سلام كل الاحترام برض وجهه
نظر اخونا دتش ب دتش امريكا مع اسرائيل
ظالمه ومظلومه امريكا مع اسرائيل في راي
ظالمه ظالمه ظالمه ابن خلدون انا لا اجد
اي مبرر انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك بس مش عارف
انا الكلام ممكن بلاش اقول لك لانه ممكن
بس باختصار يعني قصه حكيتها لكم قبل كده
انا احنا 54 سنه واحنا صغيرين كانوا
بيعلمونا ان اسرائيل دي
ظاهره استعماريه كل الكلام السلبي عن
اسرائيل لما جينا نكبر بقى شويه وتخرجنا
من الجامعه وفي اول شغلنا عاوزين نحس ان
احنا بقينا مور سفستكيتد ومثقفين فبتنا
نهتم
[موسيقى]
بالاساتذة انا بامانه يعني انا ماليش انا
مصالحي لو اعمل العكس يعني انا يعني مافيش
مصالح ممكن تحققها اكثر من ان انت
تتبنى الاجنده الاسرائيليه بجد يعني
وتتبنى الاجنده الامريكيه والغربيه بجد دي
اللي ممكن تفتح لك المصالح يعني بعيدا على
المصالح وتشكيك في نوايا اخرين يعني انه
ما فيش حاجه من اللي بتقولها امريكا
واسرائيل ممكن يبقى ضميرك مرتاح وانت
بتدافع عنهم ابدا يعني فحكايه ان امريكا
تبقى امريكا ظلمه لنفسها اذا كان قصدك كده
ماشي امريكا ظلمه
لنفسها ما في شك لده لان هي بتعتبر في
تقارب مافيش دايلايت ان مافيش فرق بين
مصالحها ومصالح اسرائيل ايه السبب ارجع
بقى للي انا قلتلك عليه لماذا يخاف
الرؤساء الامريكان من
اسرائيل مساء الخير ما علاقه ده وليد ما
علاقه المشروع الابراهيمي والخرائط
المسربه منذ سنوات الشرق الاوسط بما يحدث
الان في غزه وما قد يحدث هل ممكن اسرائيل
تفوت الفرصه لهزيمه المشروع الايراني
المنافس انا الجزء الاولاني فهمه
انه المروع الابراهيمي انه اسرائيل تبقى
حبيبه الكل على حساب القضيه الفلسطينيه ما
هو ده كان ما هو ده برض نرجع تاني انه كان
كان ممكن اسرائيل تحقق هذا القدر من
النجاح ان هي وكانت بدات تحقق نجاح ان هي
تطبع مع اكبر عدد ممكن من الدول ولكن من
غير ما تعمل اي تقدم في الملف الفلسطيني
لكن يعني ده ادى الى حاجتين اولا انه في
حاله غضب عنيف جدا مع الفلسطينيين بس
الغضب ده مش زاد بس لانه في عمليه ان
الطرب يتجاوزهم وان الاسرائيليين بيعملوا
اتفاقات مع عملوا مع مع امارات والبحرين
والمغرب وبيعملوا مع السعوديه وغيرها لا
اللي استفزهم اكتر كمان ان ده بالتوازي مع
حمله قهر غير مسبوقه في بين عرب 48 وفي
الضفه وفي غزه ناتج عن وجود حكومه بالغه
التطرف هل لو كانت الحكومه دي مش موجوده
كانت اسرائيل هتبقى دوله خير وسلام لا بس
كانت لان هي بطبيعتها واخده ارض مش
بتاعتها ف لكن ما كانش هتبقى بالغه
الاستفزاز بالشكل اللي كان ممكن يدفع حماس
الى هذه العمليه ف يعني اظن ان بالشكل ده
تطرف الاسرائيليين افسد مخططهم الابراهيمي
اللي اتكلمنا عنه مرارا وتكرارا هل ممكن
اسرائيل تفوت الفرصه لهزيمه المشروع
الايراني لو لا هي مش هتفوت الفرصه لو
قادره عليها اسرائيل بتحلم ليل ونهار
بالايراني فتفوت فرصه بس هي فين الفرصه ما
هي كمان بتحارب عدو اللي هو الايرانيين
بالنسبه لهم عدو قوي وعنده دهاء ومكره
القدره على المناوره
والتكتيك الايرانيين استراتيجيا مثيرين
للاعجاب هل انت متاكد من انا لما بقول
مثرين للاعجاب انا مش ببارك كل تصرفاتهم
لان في ناس بتبعتلي رسائل زعلانه يعني انا
في صديق سوري يقوللي انت بتقول الايرانيين
الايرانيين خربوا بلدي الايرانيين بيدعموا
النظام اللي بيقتلني انا انا مش ترف في
هذه القصه مش ترف بس لا انا ادين ده كمان
وامر سيء انا بتكلم كحد بيحلل انا بتكلم
قدره ايران للدفاع عن مصالحها بس زي ما
بتكلم عن قدره روسيا انما لما تيجي تتكلم
بقى على حساب من دي قصه تانيه فقول اللي
انت عاوزه تكرهها تحبها زي ما